Alright, so we're having a cold open contest right here. We're trying to create the world's worst cold open. Well, not yet. I'm just teeing it up. Will would you like to start the world's worst cold open? Hey man, it's freezing in here the world's worst cold open? Hey man, it's freezing in here. Who left the door open?
Pretty good. Welcome to SmartList. It feels like we haven't done this for quite a while. I know. I miss you guys. We canceled a record last week, I think. Yes, we had. So it's been a couple weeks. Is that right? Yeah.
It's been a few weeks. Well, we saw each other Saturday. We did. We did. But we haven't done this. This. We haven't done this in quite a while. We haven't. Jay, how saw each other Saturday. We did. We did, but we haven't done this. We haven't done this in quite a while. We haven't. Jay, how's your stye, by the way?
Jason's got a big stye in his right eye. It's disgusting. Are we going wide on this? I guess. I can lean in. Yes, we are. The camera here. There's a little.
You know what, it actually looks, is it better? It does look better. I started an antibiotic last night, so that's supposed to cure it. Already? Yeah, I know. You wanted to wait two weeks just to make sure. It's all about trying to find the right doctor.
So anyway, so I think I'm with the right one now, and what is now a ball bearing of pus that will not release from my eyelid, I think is gonna start to lessen and ultimately disappear. I would love that. So you found a full release doctor? I did.
Yeah. And insurance covered it all. That's so stupid. It was a small copay, but. I feel like the term doctor might be pretty loosely applied. Jay, I'm not even, Jason, I'm not even kidding. Will you please, will you please video this shit coming out? There is not gonna be, I asked him to drain me yesterday.
Hang on, hang on, again, this is the doctor. Can I get the number? Because I feel like we're getting our signals across. He said no, just take this pill and you should be okay and soon. So, stand by. Good, I hope so. Until then I'm gonna wear these glasses so people don't really see it.
Which is different, because Sean, you told me once that a guy gave you a pill and then he drained you, is that true? All for pretty affordable copay. You woke up and you had been drained. Yeah, but I willingly took the pill. By the way, speaking of stuff, I'm making this up, yesterday,
I was talking about this subject, oh, I was talking about this Saturday too. I YouTubed childbirth. I've never seen a child being birthed. I was talking about this Saturday too. I YouTube'd childbirth. I've never seen a child being birthed. What's the matter with you? I don't know, I kind of wanted to just see it. Hang on, how does your day kind of like,
kind of lay out where you find yourself on a YouTube search and then specifically for childbirth? Because I was talking to my friend Kevin about it and Carrie and she, and I don't know. Kevin and Carrie, friends of the podcast. Yeah, that's correct, and all of us. So yeah, but they, I don't know, we got on the subject of childbirth.
Oh, because a friend of mine, because a friend of mine, a friend of ours, just had a baby and Chris Pratt and Catherine Schwarzenegger had a baby boy named Ford. Yes, congrats to them. Wait, do we need to, we need to send a gift. We gotta send them something. Do you think they're registered?
Some smart little swag. No, I'll put my name on it. I'll put your names on it. I sent something, but I'll put your names on it. Thanks. So you saw the childbirth and what was your reaction? No, so I was talking to people about it and I was like, wow, I mean, I'd know.
It comes out of there? I had no idea that to watch it actually being, to come out and the doctor right there. And the head comes out all elongated. Yes, yes, and the whole body comes out. First time I saw it, I thought something was wrong. I was there for the birth of all three of my boys. Oh wow, what a dad.
And they were. All three. All three were, were cesesarean C-sections. Which was- That's tough to watch. It is, that was my point. You empty out the whole market there. Dude, and I'm like, yeah it's gonna be fun.
I remember the first time you're like, it's gonna be fun and then looking and just going, oh, oh, oh. Stomach, intestine, spleen, liver, everything on the table. By the way, you know what a platinum gay is? A baby that comes out who turns out to be gay who never even went through the canal, had a C-section.
So not only once touched, looked at it, or been through it. Is a platinum gay. That's a real term? Platinum gay. Means your mom had a C-section. Is that a whole section on Grindr? Is that a different? All rightr? Is that a different?
All right, and with that, we'll get to our guest. Okay. Guys. How is that possible? Guys, we rarely have members of the military on the show. Even more rare are members of the British military. Today we have a commander of the Royal Navy, all right? But this is not just a soldier.
His interests include rugby. Is it Churchill? Clearing. I'm gonna have to start over now. You know I don't like to be interrupted during my, I spent a long time writing these. Guys, we rarely have members of the military on this show. Even more rare are members of the British military.
Today we have a commander of the Royal Navy. But this is not just a soldier. His interests include rugby, clearing minefields, Shakespeare, Liverpool soccer, Will, solving mysteries and shaking martinis. Guys? What? It's Daniel Craig.
No way! Woo! Yep, yep, yep. Oh my God, I wanted to meet you for so long. Right there. This is so cool. Well, here we are. Will, take it easy.
Well, I know, I didn't know that you were a Liverpool supporter. This is great news. You would have covered that before when you guys met? Yeah, I would have. Wait, Daniel, I think I know what hotel room you're in. You've been in this hotel room. You're at the Four Seasons Los Angeles.
How did you guess? Is that true? Because you're on a junket, right? You're on a junket? Yeah. I've been coming to this hotel for like 35 years. Same room. They're doing the same room.
Daniel, did they make that jacket and men's or? Hey, Sean. Wow. This is one of the first minutes. And we're off. Good. Excellent. I actually love it. I actually love it.
I actually love it. Wait. Now, Sean. No, no, no. I actually really like the check. Sean, do you know Daniel as well? I don't. I've never met you, obviously.
I'm a massive. It doesn't seem like it. No. Very casual. I'm a massive, massive fan. Massive fan. I can't, yeah. OK.
And Will, you have met Mr. Craig. We have met. We hung out. We watched the Super Bowl together, right, okay, and will you have met mr. Craig we have met we hung out we had we watched the Super Bowl together Right Daniel. Yes, we did And then we went and end up in the chateau. Yes Yeah, is that way it was that after I can't remember that's yeah, I've been incidents, but there's probably no No, it was the same night. I know that we yeah, we ended up in chateau with krasinski and Sean Penn That's why I can't i'm drunk already fucking hollywood it's just it was a lot it was very hollywood it sounds like a bit but it's actually yeah that was a long time ago great group to drink with where was i damn it in a facility i was
probably in a facility somewhere figuring stuff out. It was, I think it was family weekend at Betty Ford. Um, now, Sean, we're gonna get, Sean, we're gonna get to the time when Daniel was a stormtrooper in Star Wars. We're gonna get to that. I know exactly which one he was. How about that? Truly?
Of course I do. So this is not something that I just discovered on Wikipedia. No, it's the one where he says, where she plays the mind trick, and you will walk away and drop your weapon. I will walk away and drop my weapon. You dropped your weapon, you walked out of the scene.
It's true. It's true. You spoke. Well, I didn't want to, but I just said, dub me, Christ's sake, I don't need, but then I had to wait. But that's a bump, you know, you speak as a storm trooper, that's a bump into principle.
Do you think I got one? Yeah, I'll bet. They didn't even give me the uniform. The only thing I wanted was the uniform. It was like, give me the helmet, at least. How did that come about? What do you believe? Were you visiting on the set,
and they said, here's an extra? We were about to start Which bond it was you lose track? No, no, it wasn't no it was way before that was it must have been specter because I was and we were prepping and I Knew the guys were I knew all the crew the the A.D.s worked on You drifted over to the stage Really?
And then I kind of went, oh, come on, go get me a new uniform. Yeah, I love that. I love that. Come on, truly, is that the way that it went? It went exactly, and they were like, I was half joking thinking they were just going to tell me where to get off, but I was like.
How long of a day was that? Too fucking long. Yeah. You know, that kind of regret of like, sort of think, oh no, I'll be an extra, oh yeah, it's great. Oh, how many hours were you being? I'm going to sit in the back of shot for this. It's like, they were very good. They were great.
I do remember when, cause you know, those, the suits are, I mean, they're basically hard plastic and kind of, you know, they're not comfortable. I mean, God knows how they wore them out in the desert when they do those. But I remember that it sort of was a little bit big for me and it sort of rested on my thumb and my thumb was numb for three days afterwards.
Because I was like, the price I pay, and I didn't get a bump. Right. No bump, no helmet, no nothing. You got a bump at the Chateau. Ew. Ew. Sean wants to know, did you meet the mayor of Tatooine? Fucking grow up, Sean wants to know, did you meet the mayor of Tatooine? Fucking grow up, Sean.
I would kill him. He's going to double back to this, I know it. Alright, now, Daniel... Where does Daniel... Do you have all the questions? I've got so many, yeah. And these two just fuck with you and stop you answering the questions. That's the way it goes. That's the way it goes.
Yeah. You'll be lucky to speak. What happens when the reveal and the other two go, oh fuck. That must happen, sure. It does. It does. It's happened not out loud. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. All right, now let's just, can we, I'm going to qualify this by saying, I'll bet, I'm going to ask you some questions that you've answered a thousand times, and I want you to be patient with us, because we're dumb people that aren't fully researched, we're not journalists. We're terrible interviewers.
We're just going to come at you with just dumb questions, okay? Why do I feel like I'm being hustled here? Welcome to Smarland. Now, what about... Can we start at the beginning? Sure. Alright, alright. So you're in Liverpool, alright? Yes.
By the way, you gotta see Daniel... Picture the scene. Okay, so it's gray. Yeah. It's pissing with rain. Now, was there an influence there? Mom or dad? Mom. Mom was a...
An art teacher. Art teacher, thank you. Oh wow, that's cool. And so she sort of exposed you to the arts a little bit. She took you to movies or to plays or whatnot. How did the spark start? Plays were the thing. There was a theater in Liverpool at the time,
the seventh still is called the Everyman Theatre, which was a really, was kind of a hotbed of talent, as they say, at the time in the seventies. But her friends had been at Liverpool Art College and a lot of them had gone into the theatre, stage design, and those things, and those were her kind of friends. She was a single mum. And we used to kind of end up going there most nights
to the theatre just to sort of hang out. There was a kind of, they had a bistro there. That's so cool. That served up cheap food. And it was a subsidised theatre, and they did this thing where it was like, you know, there was a pound, a ticket, it was a subsidized theater, and they did this thing where it was like, there was a pound, a ticket. It was like the whole thing was supposed to be
so everybody could afford to go. And they did some off the charts plays, but it meant that I spent sort of evenings backstage at the theater. And that'll do it to you. Yeah. Well, that's where all the fun happened. Yeah, and this is something that mom really likes,
it seems pretty cool, and on and on and on, right? And you know, actors kind of like, you know, meet actors afterwards, I'm seeing them, and I thought they were gods, and then I just realized they were drunk. Yeah, they were drunk. It's a necessary component. But they were drunk, but at the same time,
at that age, at that age, if you're quite young and you're an adolescent, you're a teenager, whatever it is, when you're exposed to that kind of thing in that kind of world, it does give you that perspective that other kids your age don't have. And you're spending a lot of time with adults who are talented, who are creative.
And when you get that fire kind of sparked at that age, I think it's pretty cool. Yeah, I mean, definitely. And I mean, it really did, it went in. That's what I wanted to do. I mean, that's all I wanted to do. But it also gave me this, it's not only watching the way a theater works and the way that professionals work and all that,
it also kind of went, oh, this is a job as well. You can see that. It's kind of a couple of things. You know, lots of things happen. When was the first time you thought, oh, this is something that I might not embarrass myself doing? When was the first time you thought I might... That hasn't happened.
What are you talking about? Second Bond film, second Bond film. The drinking component helps with that. I still feel like I'm embarrassing myself. But I mean, was it a school play where you're like, oh, I don't suck at this, or I'm getting a couple of pats on the back? I got roped into a school play.
I mean, I kind of did one of those things where I think I kind of had a couple of days off or whatever, I got the mumps or something, I don't know. And I came back and I'd been cast in the school play. And it was like, oh. What was it, do you remember what it was? It was Oliver, yeah, and I was like, oh wow. It was Mr. I wasn't Oliver.
Sadly. I was Mr. Sowersbury, which is the part that's not in the movie that kind of was in the musical and got, for good reason, got written out of the movie. Was it a spicy character though? He's an undertaker. You got to pick a pocket or two, right? I didn't get to do that, no, sadly, yeah. You got to pick a pocket or two, that's I didn't get to do that, no, sadly, yeah. You gotta pick a pocket or two, that's right.
I mean, it's a credo you live by. Right, so you do that, you get a couple of atta boys, a couple of pats on the back, and you're like, all right, well, I'm gonna lean into this a little bit, and you started maybe a little bit more sort of like... Well, I don't know about you guys, I mean, you must have all done a school play at some point. It's just that kind of mass hysteria thing
that kind of happens, which is, I mean, my kids do school plays, I love that kind of, just like the level of like, oh my God! Which is like, it kind of stays with you, it kind of, you get it. That's so true. I got asked to be in the school play and I think it was because, I'm quite sure,
never totally confirmed, quite sure it was because I was such a loud mouth, pain in the ass. No. What? No. No. Yeah, if you can believe it. And they were like, fuck, how do we, is there somewhere we can find like either a room that's soundproof or somewhere we can take
that fucking energy that's driving everybody crazy. By the way, by the way, Willie's. And they're like HMS Pinafore and I was like, okay. Yeah, that's it. Well, the same thing, the same thing. People were like, God, you're fucking loud and annoying. Yeah. Yeah, and I did Shakespeare's 12th Night,
and I was Sir Andrew Aguichig. I had no idea what I was saying. And until I got in front of the audience, then it kind of clicked, and every line that was a comedy line got a laugh, and I was like, what is that? What is that? What is that about?
Yeah, that's crazy. When you started feeling that. Yeah, yeah. The ultimate drug you wanted to avoid. Yeah, I'm like, fuck you, this loudmouth's gonna keep going. Now Daniel, you are very, very funny. Like, you know, the knife out, no, the knife out stuff
is like awesome. And then when someone says you're very, very, very funny. I can say, am I? No, but maybe it's because people weren't expecting because you've done so much incredible dramatic work. I've been so moody for 15 years. Yeah, I mean, we do what we get, you know? But now, are you starting to pursue, raise your hand,
get more scripts that are more comedic and is that something that is exciting to you? Please say yes. I never, yes, okay, yes. Yes, if you can, why don't you give me the questions and I'll just, what answers? I do build the answer to the question. The answer is always built in and so then he likes
to bring the guest into the inevitable really interesting yes or no. Is that how we go out on this? I can't wait. Fifty questions yes or no. It's easy. So you want to do more comedy? Yes.
Listen, it would be like I had a plan. Right, yeah, yeah. I mean, I'm making this up as I go along. I don't know about that. I mean, seriously, it's like, if they come along, sure, but I'm kind of going out and looking for something funny. It's also, I know how kind of that's a dangerous thing to do, you know, it's like, the first night out,
I read the script and I laughed out loud and I went fuck. I mean that was like an easy, easy pick. And then Ryan's one of the most talented writers there are. He just kind of keeps going and keeps getting at it and keeps getting into it. And this next one's gonna be different. And we've kind of gone, I mean it's not wildly different,
but it's gonna be definitely kind of get a different tone to it. Oh wait, there's a third one you're doing now? There's a third one we shot at the summit. It's called Wake Up, Deadman. Oh wow. Wow. It's like plugging the movie.
Yeah. Yeah, no, no, please. Yeah, come on. Yeah. Right, but I mean you say that there's no, like that you have some sort of a plan or something, but I would guess that somebody who is approached for something as iconic as Bond
and the kind of intelligence that you have, you probably had some thoughts and some talks with some people about, okay, if I did this, I've got to do this, but if I did this, I would need to kind of have a plan how to occupy myself in between those movies and what to do afterwards. Which I just fucked up.
I don't think so. I don't think so. I think it's kind of perfect. We're going to get to Queer soon, which is a perfect balance. By the way, you didn't need to plan for anything. I guess we're going to get to them right now. Go ahead.
There's our clip. Go ahead, Sean. No, I was going to say, you didn't need to plan because those movies were fucking exhausting, I'm sure. Yeah. Didn't you need to recover? I think there was a feeling when I first started that because I'd had exactly what you said, those conversations, and I talked about it to everybody I knew and my family and all of those things about what does it mean. Of course I've got to do it. I've got to do this, but what does it, those conversations. And I talked about it to everybody I knew, and all my family, and all of those things about what does it mean, of course I've got to do it,
I've got to do this, but what does it mean? I mean, how it's going to affect my life, and all those things. And there was a sort of, I suppose, an instinct in me to sort of want to go, okay, I'm doing Bon and now I've got to do other stuff as well to kind of counterbalance this. It's just like fucking ridiculous.
It's just like, I mean, it's like, I was fucking exhausted. I was like, so as much as the moves I did in between, I'm kind of like proud of and all of those things, I stopped, I just went, just do this. If I'm doing this, just do this. And I don't have the head space. I don't have the, I mean. I'm going to say something that's going to be,
it's not controversial, but I know because the Bond fans in the Bond world is so, those fans are so vocal and dedicated, et cetera. But I will say that for me, and I loved all the prior Bonds, everybody was great. So this is by no means an admonishment of what they had done. But you were the first Bond who was like a real like, real man's man. Yeah, piece of ass.
And was tough. You were tough. This is controversial, where's it getting controversial? Yeah, exactly. Well no, but you came, you were tough, and because I think that people will go like, how dare you, blah, blah, blah. But you came out and you were like this tough,
like you were like a real modern Bond in a way that I thought was really, really refreshing. I loved your Bond films, dude. I really did. Absolutely, thank you. Yeah, yeah. And we will be right back. And now, back to the show.
My question is when you were doing the very first one, which I've seen a billion times, I've seen all of them a billion times. I literally could do like dialogue from it. I know I've seen it a billion times. Okay, go. Give it to me. Stop, what did you say?
Take your hand away from your ear. Anyway, that was the first one. Anyway, so thank you, thank you. Question. Uh. But wait, at what point? That would have been the line I remembered too. Go ahead.
I literally just said it yesterday. It's iconic. It's better. But wait. Get to the choppas, right? It's up there with that. But wait, Daniel. At what point when you were making that move.
Sorry, I think my phone's ringing. No, that kicked off the whole chase. Get your hand over here. But anyway, so when you were doing that movie, at what point in the middle of the movie were you like, oh God, I bit off more than I could chew, this is really hard. Like, I don't know if I'm going to make it.
Or were you like, oh, this is awesome, I can do this. All the stunts, all the bullshit that you had, that you put your body through. I mean, I was sort of younger and I'm way too gung ho. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I was just, you know, I mean, I kind of threw myself. There was, you know, the guys were kind of saying, you know, do you want to do, yeah, I'll do, yeah!
I was like, yeah, and then we were like, yeah, I know. But I had all this stuff going on. We started shooting in Prague, in studios there, and then we moved to the Bahamas, and then my agent, which was very nice, but then my agent phoned me up and said, you might want to look at the internet, and the internet has just sort of blown up.
I've done this like, fuck him, kind of thing. Yeah, yeah, I remember that. Which was kind of like, and I kind of looked at it all and as like, you know, when, the naive days when I used to do stuff like that, like oh no, I'm going to look at all and go down that rabbit hole and just chased it all night long and was like oh my god,
that's really intense and I kind of, I then sort of just had this sort of like, sort of, I don't know, I just sort of went, well, fuck all I can do about that. There's nothing I can do, and we're here, and I know the script's good, and let's have a good time. And if it's a swing and a miss, great. If it's my last one, I'll walk away knowing
that I did the best I could. I mean, it kind of, it sounds easy to say now. But it just, it was like, it just, I was like, let's get on with this. Let's do it. I just, you know. And do you think, do you think that, that sort of that trial by fire of, of being, because Bond again is so iconic and by being put in the brightest of spotlights and being scrutinized so much, sort of on social media or whatever it is online, do you think that that was a, were you able to carry those lessons on sort of post bond and in your normal life?
So as you, because we talk about it sometimes, what's the reaction to what people say in social media and everybody's got a voice and stuff and everybody kind of puts it in a different place or deals with it differently. How does it affect your life? Do you think about it? I mean, I think the fame thing, I mean, I just had a complete nervous breakdown after it came out and sort of didn't leave the house for six months. Really? I mean, I mean, I exaggerate, but I kind of was a bit like that. I just got like, oh my, I mean, it was like, It's a level of fame and recognizability that is not something that one deals with quickly and easily. Well, and how do you talk to about it?
I mean, I suppose you go, I'm going to phone up someone really, really famous. I mean, it's like, I don't know what you say. Yeah, or if you talked to the butcher or your friend or somebody who's not working and they're like, oh boo-hoo, you're James Bond, right? Exactly, exactly. Right, so where does that healthy level of indifference
come from about whether it works or not and I'm going to still just be me and if it doesn't or this fame stuff, like, was your, did mom give you a good head on your shoulders or was it sort of, were you kind of self-taught? I think there's a, I've just got a very, you know, down to earth family who do not shy away from telling me what a low life I am.
I mean it's like, and that really helps. And just, yeah, coming, I don't know, I'm from the north of England, it's a more kind of like sort of practical sort of pragmatic way of looking at life maybe. I also got into that thing of very early on, I went to drama school and there's that terrible thing of drama school is that like 90% of the year don't get to work. It's like that's the attrition rate
and you go into the business, there wasn't social media so there wasn't another outlet to try and become famous. It was just like you got a job or you didn't get a job and mostly people didn't get a job. I know that somebody gave me a great bit of advice very early on while at drama school, a great director who just said, don't ever, ever, ever get bitter. Don't get, you know, because bitterness is just the thing
that it'll just eat you up, because there's always somebody gonna get the job or the bug put over you. There's always somebody gonna, you know, and if you kind of only look at other people in the business with jealousy, then that'll define you. And it doesn't matter if you then get success, you'll still kind of, I get jealous all the time,
jealous of every fucking actor out there who gets the job that I'd like. But I admit to it. I'm jealous. You know? But that's good. We had the same, we used to talk about it all the time. I remember this was years ago
when people would start to work. And as you say, most of the time, most of us were not working and somebody would get a good job and whatever. And I always stayed friends with, we sort of cultivated. The people who were working. Yeah, it's a good boy.
Good boy. No. They'll always get dinner. Yeah. Well, it was, but it was also like, we genuinely rooted for each other. And anybody, and sometimes there would be somebody who would come in the group who was, you could tell was keeping score.
No, and that, I just frequently am. And then you would just weed them out. And you'd weed them out. And you'd be like, I'm not here, I can't be friends with people who are keeping score. I just can't. I agree. There's enough for everybody
Yeah, and and if you're not in the mindset of rooting people on and like you say you're bitter and then fuck then you're fucked Yeah, I thought that's why I thought I just read something recently where you said and I made me laugh out loud when somebody asked you Who do you think you should pass the torch on to for James Bond? You said I don't care Not my business. JB that is sexy indifference. Somebody else's fucking problem. That made me laugh out loud. So then coming up and starting to do some jobs and kind of starting to make a living
a little bit from it perhaps, were there some other, I'm sure that there were some other jobs that you were doing to kind of starting to make a living a little bit from it, perhaps, were there some other, I'm sure that there were some other jobs that you were doing to kind of pay the bills. I mean, I left home at 16. Yeah. Wow. I went and joined a thing called the National Youth Theatre in London, so I left Liverpool. Liverpool was like, early 80s, as depressed as,
I mean, so much, it's come up now and the city's doing great, which is just wonderful. But at the time, it was seriously depressed. We had a sort of Trotskyite local council that was hated by Thatcher, who she starved. I mean, it was like the whole thing was just like, employment was like, I can't even, like 35% or 36%, but it was through the roof, whatever it was.
And there was not a lot of job prospects. And I was playing with the idea of joining the roof, whatever it was. And there was not a lot of job prospects. And I was playing with the idea of joining the Navy. I was playing with the idea. You know, I was doing all those things going, well, what do I do? What the fuck do I do? There was nothing to do. And there was a thing called the National Youth Theater,
and it did a summer course, and my mother was a teacher, and it was on the board at her school, and she went this. And I went and auditioned for it in Manchester. I got in, and she sort of kicked me out the door, and she went, you gotta go, you gotta go, go, go, go. And it was partly her ambition because actually she'd got into RADA, which is the kind of top, the top sort of drama school,
certainly of those years, when she was 17, 18 and there was no money to go. There was like, because she didn't, the family just didn't have the money. So she didn't tell me that until about 10 years ago, actually. Oh, wow. Wow. So she, but her ambition for me was just to get going. She must've been absolutely thrilled with your success
and the arc of your success too, yeah? Yeah, I mean, I think so, yes. Yeah, that's awesome. Awesome, awesome, awesome. And also, and when you say the arc of your success too, yeah? Yeah, I mean, I think so, yes. Yeah, that's awesome. Awesome, awesome, awesome. And also, and when you say the arc too, because you earned it as well. Like, you know, you really. Oh, there she is.
Is that your mom? Look at that. Hey! We already tipped her, by the way, don't. We got this, we got that. Listener, he just had some food delivered. I gotta have a bite of this, I'm sorry. Go ahead, we're doing this. Go on, yeah, yeah.
Enjoy. So this is a perfect time for me with a long-winded question here so you can choose. Now, let's see, were there weren't any, well, you tell me, were there huge influences or a particular one coming out of England that you were like, if I were to get some traction on this career, that is kind of the path I'd like to be on.
Was it somebody in England or was it somebody in America? Was it always acting, was it directing? The theater thing was the kicker. That was definitely the kind of thing that got me, just, that's what I want to do. And I had some weird thing that I can do that, which is great, but it's just because I was a show off. Right, right. I'm not dressing up, as want to do. And I had some weird thing that I can do that, which is great, but you know, it's just because I was a show off.
Right, right. I'm not dressing up. So was it like? As I still do. Yeah. So it's like, you know, I mean, so. John Gielgud. Something like that, no?
Do you want to try to take me? Yes. I mean, I don't know. Albert Finney. I mean, definitely that generation, Albert Finney's generation, and those guys, I mean, it's just that whole, you know, I suppose they called the angry young men, didn't they?
Then you worked with Cam Bond, right? I did, yeah, yeah. Oh my God, lucky man. I'm really, I mean just a dream. Yeah. Of a human being and one of the greatest actors ever. Yeah. It was film, really.
And that was, we had a little cinema in the town I grew up in, which was, you know, a flea pet, proper, kind of just like a one screen. And all the movies at the time would do the kind of rounds of the country where they'd go to the big screens and things like that. And then by the time we got them, the movie had been out for like a month and a half. And the prints would, I don't remember, the prints were just terrible. But they just, they put films on in rotation. I mean, from Stripes to Quest for Fire, to, you know, I mean, Blade Runner,
I remember seeing in the cinema on my own, with kind of an orange juice and this film came out, I had no idea, it was like blind. I was in there seeing a double bill. It was a Sean Connery space movie called Outland or something. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah. Does that make sense?
Yeah, yeah. That was on, which was pretty great, because it's a cowboy movie in space. And then I kind of went and got a drink and came back and sat down on my own and Blade Runner started. And it was just like, I was like, and that. Was Harrison Ford a bit of a North Star for you?
Well, it was the movie itself, it was the whole thing. Yeah. I mean, sure, he is, of course, but the movie itself and the kind of, the fact that movies could look like that, feel like that and do that to you. Right. Was just like the thing.
I did, I'd never kind of experienced it. And it felt like a movie that I discovered, that I was, and it was nothing to do with the gun with the wind or the kind of, it's a wonderful life stuff, or the Bond movies even. That was part of, you know. But ultimately kind of intangible though, right? I would imagine there you are sitting in this theater
in this small town and you're like, well I'm never going to make it to Hollywood, I'm never going to be up there. That's a million miles away. I was an arrogant little bitch. You actually thought, there is a shot, there's a shot. If I play my cards right, if I get this. I don't know, I mean, it's hindsight, isn't it,
that sort of says it, but there was something about. You thought it was possible, which is the key, right? I think so. Why can't, well. But you also got accolades when you were doing theater enough to know that you had something to offer. It was the thing that happened.
I kind of left drama school and went and did, I went and did a John G. Avilsdorff movie called The Power of One with Stephen Dorff. Loved Stephen. Scored by Hans Zimmer. I mean, amazingly. Wow. And really kind of weird, I mean, not weird, maybe just a kind of movie of its era. Playing the bad guy and kind of, it was just this sort of event that happened, but it was
a movie. And I then came out, I didn't work for a lot, did some theater and then started getting TV roles. Little guest roles and things like that. And suddenly then I got kind of a lead in a TV role and suddenly the money started. It wasn't great but it was like, well, this is like kind of life changing money in the sense I might be able to afford a house soon. Still living in England? Still living in England.
I'd gone to LA after the Power of One. And it was like 1991 and arriving here. Kind of and kind of not because I was so green and naive. I landed in this town, I didn't have a driver's license, and I didn't have a credit card. me into the Universal Sheraton, which I realize now is an island. You need a car to get off it. I kind of went to the front desk and they said, credit card. They were looking at me like I had to embarrassly call up Warner Brothers and get them to put
some money down on the desk and do all these things. And then John D. Alvison very nicely was sort of pushing me slightly because he's like, you kid, this kid's got it, this kid's got it, he was pushing me slightly. So I went up for auditions and in the movie I was playing a Nazi kind of South African bad guy. And I was going up for Nazi South African bad guys. I mean that was it. I went up for like five auditions and it was all for,
you know, it was all for the Nazis. And I just was like, I was just like, yeah, I mean, I've got a bit more range than this, I think. And there was a kind of, suddenly there was an offer on the table from a manager, and why don't you stay and we get you accommodation, blah, blah, blah, blah. And I kind of went on and I did these five auditions and I went, whoa, no, this is going to go really wrong. And I don't know what it was, it was just like,
where these thoughts came from, I have no idea. But they were just like, this is not the career I want. So I went home. Back to England, back to theater. Back to England, well, sort of back to thinking, well, I've got a bit of money in my pocket, I've got a bit of money now, so it's okay. But then suddenly I started getting bigger roles
in television, and I realized that was a mistake. Because I looked at these bit of money now, so it's okay. But then suddenly I started getting bigger roles in television and I realized that was a mistake because I looked at these television stars at home and God bless them, they're earning money and they've got the house in Portugal and they're thinking, yeah, they're set, set, it's great. I want to make movies, I want to make movies. Good for you. And the British movie industry didn't exist.
Right, it just didn't. I mean, there were amazing movies coming out. You think about, you know, like... Room with a view. I mean, room with a view, but I'm talking kind of like, I mean, no one was ever going to cast me in. Because I wasn't a floppy-fringed kind of posh boy. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Well, that's what I mean.
Like the sort of the... So there was lots of brilliant directors, like, you know, my beautiful Laundrette, and the sort of the... So there was lots of brilliant directors like, you know, my beautiful Laundrette and things like that were going on. But that was a kind of, you know, you had to know the director and things and I sort of plugged away at it until someone gave me a break. But what was the shift in that in the British film? For me? I mean, yeah.
I did a film called Love is a Devil. And that was, that got some traction for you? It's as these things do. Like I say this to young actors, they talk about when the break comes, and I'm going to do this thing. It's like believing producers say, this is going to be good for you,
this is going to be good for you, this. It doesn't happen like that in the industry. It's tectonic. It rolls around. You get the break, someone comes and sees you in something, or sees you in something, a year later they might go, let's tectonic, it's like it rolls around. You get the break, like someone comes and sees you in something or sees you in something, a year later they might go, let's get that guy.
And you can't rush these things. So I did things and I just kept on going and eventually sort of something, momentum started happening and then I don't know what kind of went down. I did a TV series and then wrote a petition, like you know, Sam cast me and wrote a petition, and then Munich. Did you know Sam Mendes before that?
To say hello to. Yeah, so then it was, so then when you audition, I'd imagine that was an audition, not an offer. It was a friendly face in the audition room. I blew it. You did? No. Not a good audition.
Come on. No. Did you apologize audition. Come on. No. Did you apologize after your audition? As you're leaving, I'm so sorry you had to see that. Good luck with the project. That's my go-to. It works.
Sometimes it works. Sometimes it works, yeah. I was supposed to have learnt this Chicago accent. For some reason, I didn't. I was supposed to have learnt this Chicago accent. For some reason, I didn't. I was supposed to have learnt this Chicago accent. I was supposed to have learnt this Chicago accent.
I was supposed to have learnt this Chicago accent. I was supposed to have learnt this Chicago accent. I was supposed to have learnt this Chicago accent. I was supposed to have learnt this Chicago accent. I was supposed to have learnt this Chicago accent. I was supposed to have learnt this Chicago accent. I was supposed to have learnt this Chicago accent. I was supposed to have learnt this Chicago accent, but for some reason I didn't. For the audition, I kind of, I really couldn't. He hadn't offered it to me, but he sort of said to me, we really want you to play the part. I thought, well, that's an offer.
And he said, now you've got to fly out to Chicago and audition. I was like, really? Yeah. So I didn't really do enough work on the part. I kind of went, did this terrible reading, and he sort of went, stop, stop, you've got the job. Oh, I don't want to. I sort of, I kind of, you know,
batted him down with terrible acting. It's a ploy. All right, so then you're on set, and you're working with Tom Hanks and Paul Newman and being directed by Mr. Mendez. Tom Hanks and Paul Newman and being directed by Mr. Mendez, did you get winded or was it just sort of like, yeah, this is kind of, it's about time and off we go. And this is what I've been trying to do.
I've been trying to avoid the other stuff and now I've landed in the sort of the lane I want to be in a little bit. I mean. Convo? I mean, I would, I kind of, yeah. I mean, I just felt, I felt like terrified and all of those things, but like, you're here now.
Right. You better fucking. You better deliver. You better deliver. And did you find that you had a gear that you didn't know that could kind of boost you up and so you didn't have a panic attack and you held your own, yes?
I mean, I suppose what it was, what really calmed me when it boils down to it, you're on set with one of the greatest living actors of all time. And Paul Newman. And Paul Newman. Both of them, but very, very, very different actors. But Paul Newman, who I've idolized, and watching him work, you realize, oh god, he's an actor. And it's just
that sort of like that in itself was like, he's, I can't talk to him about, he wanted to talk to me about racing cars. I was like, going four wheels? I mean, you know, because like, he's like talking about like, I mean, I just, why the indie series was so much better than the Grand Prix series? I was like, yeah. And it was like, I couldn't. But when it came down to it and watching and working with him,
I had a language that I could speak to him in, because I'm an actor, he's an actor, and he really is, you know. And he'd struggle and he'd really be kind of trying to find it and things like that, just be like, oh wow, great, that's what I do. Oh good, yeah. And that kind of just, so I can get, you know, I mean. He forgets a line too sometimes. Right, yeah.
Oh that's great. That's really cool. Yeah, that's really interesting, that idea of being with Paul Newman and watching him kind of find it in the scene. That is the opposite of making you nervous, it actually calms you because you see him as human. Yeah, you must have had a complete, like your nerves must have been absolutely settled in that moment.
I was like, we can do this, we can make this happen, we're playing. Suddenly we're like, we're here to play, great, I know how to play. Fascinating. One time I was doing the bucket list with Jack Nicholson and Morgan Freeman. I was in a scene with Jack Nicholson. Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you. And he turns to me and he goes, during rehearsal he goes, do you know what you mean when you say that line?
I go, yeah, do you? Ha! Like, what? Nice dick. I had to say that. You're a dick. Yeah, in your head. I had to say that to relax myself because I couldn't believe I was in a movie with Jack Nicholson. We'll be right back.
And now back to the show. Now Daniel, when you were very quickly after that, sort of vaulted into much more of a leadership position on the jobs that followed, did you take that experience with you as a leader and see the younger actors, or the actors with lesser parts, get a little sort of nervous?
And did you lend some of that comfort to them by, not intentionally forgetting a line, but did you lend some of that comfort to them by, not intentionally forgetting a line, but did you take some of those leadership lessons? By being completely shit. Yeah. It really just settles everybody's nerves. Oh my God. Fake a panic attack.
That's how he's going to do it. I don't know, I mean, I feel like part of my job is to, you know, you're on set. I love being around actors. I love being, you know, it's fun. It's a lot of fun. If you have somebody who is there for a bit, short day, I have a thing. It's like my favorite movies, it's those small parts that zip out, that make the movie sometimes. It's like you encourage them to be the best they can because it's like, you know, it's like, Smallest Cogs, all of that shit.
Sure, there's no small parts, there's small actors. Exactly. Yeah. What about siblings? Do you have siblings? I have a half brother, an sister, an older sister. And different, completely different career path than you? Completely different, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, yeah. I mean, I'm kind of the only actor in the family. And I want to talk about eggs that you just ate. Do you always watch what you eat when you're on doing these junkets? Like, you didn't want to touch the potatoes. I was just watching you garble those eggs.
Sean knows, can he send a guy over to pick up the potatoes? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. There's somebody at your door right now, Daniel, if you don't mind, just real quick. Just slide the potatoes under the door. No, are you always like that,
or do you go off the rails sometimes? I mean, I do, I used to swing on Bond. I'll finish this. Yeah, right, here we go. Unless that's not a good word. to swing on Bond. That's not a good word. On Bond, because of the intensity, I would then spend the next three, four months being drunk and eating.
That's not good for you. I stopped doing that and said, okay, let's maintain my fitness. How about that? Yeah, yeah, yeah. You my fitness, how about that? And I thought, thank you. It gets so hard after 50, yeah? I mean, we're all in our 50s. It's so depressing. It's so depressing.
I remember before I found my mom up a few years ago and going, oh, my fingers are aching, and just, welcome to my world. I mean, it's just that, it's just that's what it is. I've got all these little hotspots on my hands now that like, it hurts between this finger and this finger and right at the base of the thumb there, it's like, what's going on?
I had this treatment the other day where they gave me this infrared thing where they kind of map your body infrared and my hands were on fire and they were like, we're going, oh, what's wrong? And I'm like, I don't know what is wrong. It's like, it hurts. I'm not 20.
Wait a second, wait, Sean, you did a similar, no, JB, you did a math thing. I did the full body scan, yeah. Full body scan. And it was, thank God, it was all good, but it's kind of cool that they can do that now. What did they find in the place where the human heart normally is?
Not much. There was like, a little movie camera rolling in there. Just a bunch of loose nuts and bolts. Wait, Daniel, also just meeting you for the first time, I sense that your brain works really, really fast. Like you're hyper intelligent and you kind of have to when you're doing all the things that you do. What do you do to slow it?
I'm not getting that, Sean. Really? I do, I get that you're like, your brain works really, really fast. Like you're eating the eggs and you're finishing the story and then you're going like, you ever see? He's not a dummy, okay?
I know that's what I'm saying. Sean's so shocked. How is he chewing and walking at the same time? By the way, this is coming from a guy who spends a Monday afternoon, mid-afternoon watching videos of Childbirth. He's a childbirth. So it's not like he doesn't have a lot going on.
Yeah, it's gonna feel like doesn't have a lot going on. Yeah, it's going to feel like a compliment's coming, but the curve is... Yeah, the bar could be fucking lower. No, it is a big compliment because you have to think, you constantly have to think fast of what you do. You're like, the camera's there, my line's here, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
and you have kids and you have the thing. So your mind's always going, what do you do to calm down? I don't know. I mean, it's just being at home. And I like to, I really, really, really don't play tennis. I'm so terrible. But if I can convince, you know, like a tennis pro or someone to hit a ball with me,
I'll do that for two, three hours at a time. Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's good. I just kind of like, and you know. No golf for you? Yeah, whatever, what's the, ruin's a good walk, what are you talking about? Yeah, but it is a nice walk.
It is a great, great walk. Now what about, now you've been to all these incredible, in all the films you've done, all these incredible locations around the world, is there a spot that calms you more than any, a favorite spot? I think if I'm going to really relax, the sea is like the place I want to be, because it's like, I just want the salt water,
and I want the sun, and my body kind of, again with the aches and the pains. You're not a boat guy though, are you? Are you a guy that? Not really, they're kind of, that's a lot of hard work. Yeah. I have like two fan stuff, can we just get it out of the way?
Yeah, of course, man. Because Scotty, my husband and I watched all your films like a billion times. The Javier Bardem and you probably have the greatest hero villain chemistry of all time, like just incredible what Do you tell Tracy what that's for Tracy's that's from? Oh my god. That's from my full skyfall. Thanks And do you a talent you have to sing Adele whenever say the net? No, you don't go ahead with the question
No you don't. Go ahead with the question. No, the... No, I just... It's just a comment, not a question. It's just a comment. Like, that was incredible. And do you guys still... Do you still keep in touch with Javier? I do. I see. I talk to him occasionally and yes, I love him to death. He's just... He's just like... He's a glorious human being. So good. And then the other thing was, and you can think about it while we talk about other stuff,
unless you have to go, is a great theater story. I was asked, like, people with theater while we talk about other stuff, unless you have to go, is a great theater story. I always ask people with theater stories, like scenes falling, like people throwing up on stage, like anything like that. I've done all that, I've done all that. Really? Yeah, I've done all that. Really?
You name it. The amount of theater you've done is just stunning. I've done it, it's happened on stage. What do you think was the worst thing that happened where you were like fucked up a performance or like an audience member? I haven't, I mean, I've been at the theater when it was actually, Leo Schreiber was doing,
what are they doing, a few from the bridge, but where literally someone had a thing, an attack, and Leo actually got to say, is there a doctor in the house? I mean, he was like, wow, it's like, and there was, and the guy was fine, and it was all good. I was kind of like, yeah, they stopped the show. So the amount of work that goes into doing theater
at the level that you've done and that Sean just did, is it, I'm sure you can't compare that to the kind of rigor it takes to get through a huge, huge film, but is it somewhat comparable? And if so, which do you prefer as far as what takes most out of you? I think a movie takes the most out of you because I think it's a seven day a week job. It's not that you can't get, there's no day off really because there's always something to do on whatever.
Either you're doing a five day a week or you're doing a six day a week. You're either rehearsing something or you're studying something. So the intensity of that is like, there's nothing. And a play once it's up and running gets its own kind of momentum. I mean, if it's an emotionally difficult play, then obviously it's kind of like it gets, you know, but you sort of tend to be able to kind of like spend the day not thinking about it. And then go and do it.
Do you see yourself staying on screen until you're old and gray and in the ground? Or would you like to sort of throttle back and just have the last section of your life whenever that starts, just on theater. Because that's something that I kind of fantasize about, is just like moving to New York and becoming a theater actor and just like riding my bike to the theater.
It's very attractive. I mean, I don't know, it depends how big the bills are, isn't it, right? Yeah, that's true. Well, back to the TV stars. Yeah, exactly, I mean, right, so, I don't know. I did work with Gilgud. I worked with Gilgud on two jobs.
He was actually in The Power of One. I played the headmaster at this school, and I did have a scene with him, but I met him. I met him around the back of the set, because I'd gone around to have a cigarette back in the day when I smoked. And there he was, smoking. And he kind of went, oh, don't tell anybody
I'm not supposed to be smoking. And I was like, I thought we had a cigarette together and had a chat, which was like, you know. And then I did Elizabeth about 10 years later, and he must have been well into his 90s by then. Wow. And it was kind of, why is he working? Because his boyfriend liked diamonds.
I mean, it was kind of like he was that, that was the response, you know, it was that. And he was wheeled in, and I kind of thought I had the scene with him, just to sort of like, he was playing the pope, and I was playing this Jesuit mass murderer. Easy role. I just sort of, I kind of went to take care of him.
My instinct was to sort of tell him, how are you, you probably don't remember, we had a cigarette together, you know, and of course he didn't remember. But he was like, I could see the age, and he was like, oh my God, wow, he's really kind of, is he going to be able to remember his lines? The board went on, bang.
Just showed up. The back went up when he was just like, and he did the scene like, it was like, oh man, blew everybody away, and then kind of went back, and it was like, wow, that's, that's, and I kind of was like, that's amazing, but I was also kind of like, I don't know if you've ever ridden a horse in a movie. They have to retire movie horses
because they learn the board. They learn. When the sleigh comes in and they hit it whack, it's time to go. Yeah, so I've sat on horses that are kind of like, wait a minute, you know, because I don't ride very well, I was sticking on that nag, you know,
it's because it's like, and they're kind of like there, and the dog's trying to pull its head up, trying to look cool, but it's just like, it's because it's like, and they're kind of like there, and the dance mat's trying to pull its head up, trying to look cool, but it's just like, look, it's like it's going to die. And they put the board on it, and it's like, it's, oh my God, Jesus Christ! And they can't, they have to retire these horses. And I thought, oh my God, you're a film horse.
That's kind of what, do I want to turn into a film horse? When that board goes on, oh yeah, here we are, here we are. But at the same time, I mean, maybe there's a little bit of wisdom in staying active in that way is part of the reason that he was able to be alive in his 90s. I mean, maybe do a crossword, I don't know. Yeah, because otherwise he's in Portugal, right? No, totally, totally, I get it. I mean, going back to that hysteria in the school play,
that thing, that drug, that thing that gets you in the... See how I brought it back there? It's really good. You know, I like it. I like it. I kind of wanted to get back, I'm glad you mentioned that, because I kind of wanted to go back to that moment
you're in the theater, and go all the way back to that moment you're in the theater, you're watching Blade Runner, because it really made me think about, I was going to bring this up before, and I was going to ask you guys, what is that thing? What was that sort of seminal moment in your life? What was the film, the book that you read,
and do you go back and still, because I have found now that I'm in my 50s, I'm now re-looking for moments like that where I get inspired, I'm reading a book right now. That's called Midlife Crisis. It is a midlife crisis, believe me. I should be wearing a fucking hat the last 10 years that said ask me about my midlife crisis. It is a midlife crisis. Believe me, I should be wearing a fucking hat the last 10 years that said,
ask me about my midlife crisis. Yeah. But, and yes, I had a Porsche, obviously, and I've had, but all of that, do, you know, do you guys, have you guys had those moments? Do you remember being young in a book or a film or something?
Yes. You went like. Mine is 11 years old. I was 11 years old. My brother took me for my 11th birthday. Have you guys had those moments? Do you remember being young in a book or a film or something? You went like... Mine is 11 years old. I was 11 years old. My brother took me for my 11th birthday. My brother, Kevin, took me to go see E.T. And I was 11 years old. And everybody in the theater was crying,
as they were at the end. And I said to my brother, I said I'd give anything to be him. And my brother thought, like the fantasy, like, oh, Elliot, to have a friend like E.T. And I go, no, I'd give anything to be Henry Thomas my brother thought, the fantasy, like, oh, Elliot to have a friend like E.T. and I go, no, I'd give anything to be Henry Thomas. Who played Elliot.
And my brother's like, the actor? And I was like, yeah, to make people feel that? That would be amazing. JB, anything, do you remember a moment you were inspired by something? Matthew Broderick to Brighton Beach Memoirs on Broadway. I think I was like 15 or something. And I could have gone, there was like,
I was a fork in the road. I could have stopped doing what I was doing. But I saw him do that and I just had such a good time. And I was like, oh, I want to do that. Keep doing that. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. For me, it wasn't even seeing, for me it was, I was 17, I remember this so clearly,
and I read On the Road by Jack Kerouac. And it sounds so cliche, but fuck, I was 17, I remember this so clearly, and I read On the Road by Jack Kerouac, and it sounds so cliche, but fuck, I was like, you can get out into the world? And that was actually spurred me to go, I can move to New York, and I moved when I was 20, and it was like, yeah, fucking Kerouac, that's what they did. Where did you grow up?
In Toronto, Canada, and you're like, that's what you do. If you wanna be out in the world, you gotta get out into the world, and that really spurred me on for the rest of my life. I love that. and you're like, that's what you do. If you want to be out in the world, you got to get out into the world. And that really spurred me on for the rest of my life. I love that. Daniel, what's going to happen with you for the rest of the day?
And by the way, you live- We're going to talk about Queer. I want to hear a little bit about Queer. So Queer's out December 13th. You read the script, you think immediately. Do you think about the character? Are you thinking about that incredible director, Luca, Guadagnino?
Or what, what's going through your mind? Is it a quick yes? All of that, all of that. Yeah, all of that. That's like, I mean, I just, I wanted to work with Luca. I think he's, you know, he's just a really Incredible. Just exciting, kind of out there director
who's just pushing it. But so it was a pretty quick yes, yes? Totally, yeah. Yeah. And the script, you know, was, I mean, yeah, I mean, getting offered a really complicated, interesting, funny, sad human being to play. I can't wait to see it.
I know, me too, me too. Congratulations on that. Yeah, thank you. All right, you're done, you've done great. Yeah, now you. Yeah. All right, you're done. You've done great. Yeah, now you can get your cold eggs there. I'm very sorry. That's all right, I'm just not going to eat
the potatoes in front of you. Sean will be here soon. But that's my personal, I've got a problem with that. I'll take them off your hands. I have to go to a dark cupboard and eat potatoes. Wait, Daniel, how, like, do you live in the UK? I do, I lived in New York, I lived in New York for nearly 20 years,
no, 15 years, but, and moved back to London this summer. And do you love visiting LA, or are you like, I'm in, I'm out? I mean, it's kind of, you know, it's love-hate, it's all that thing, it's like, I really, I do love this, and I love California, and I love, I just, I went to the desert for a couple of days before I started this to get some kind of R&R.
And it's like there's no place like this on Earth and then I want to leave really quickly. Now, last question, do you still follow Liverpool at all? Yes, yeah. You do? I do, yeah, religiously, yeah. Yeah, same. I don't get to many games, sadly, but now You do? I do, yeah, religiously, yeah. Same. I don't get to many games, sadly, but now I'm back in England.
I'm hoping to get to New York. Let's come in the New Year. I'm going to come over there. Let's go to a game. Let's make this pledge. I would really like that. Okay, great. Yeah, I really like that.
Daniel, thank you so much for doing this. Thank you. Thank you. I love you, Stan. Thank you. All right, buddy. Bye. Thank you.
I don't know how to stop this. There you go. Ah ha ha. Now there's a guy's guy. He's a woman's guy too. And he slammed the computer. You know, that's a great sign. Yeah, yeah. You love that, JB. I really do. He is, he's great.
Like, you know, how do you talk to him without bringing up James Bond? I can't tell if he's sick of it or he's like. I think we did a good job of not peppering him with all the shit he's been asked, maybe. I don't know, I've never seen an interview with him. I mean, I always say this on this little podcast of ours, is like, when I meet people I've never met before like that,
and I'm huge fans, of course I want to ask them all the fan questions, but I'm nervous. Yeah. I know. You know, like... How many films have you seen a billion times? I want to get down to your numbers now. Yeah, I mean, I've honestly, I've seen that so many times. I've seen all of them so many times.
But Skyfall is Scottie's favorite. And we've seen that many, many times. I want to see that, that's incredible. It's really good. Skyfall? You've never seen Skyfall? That's the one, right? Oh, it's so good. Wait, are you kidding, Jay?
It's so good. No, I'm not. Invite me over for Christ's sake. Wait, Jason, Skyfall is amazing. Yeah, it's amazing. I want to see it. And you love Javier Bardem. He takes his teeth out and is fucking crazy. Spoiler alert.
Wait, what's your favorite line that he ever said? Oh, yeah. Oh, this, my ear. I hear it through my ear. Take your hand away from your ear. Take your hand away from your ear. Oh, what a line. Yeah.
No, because it kicked up the whole thing. Is James Bond around? That was another one. Yeah, nearly lost a mark. Is James Bond around? That was another one. No, but- Go ahead, go ahead, Sean. Oh, Sean, hey Sean, I know you were gonna say, fuck me, dude, watching your face try to line up on by. Because he looks down at the computer,
because he kind of works on them, I think. Of course he does. No, no, I had one, I have one. Have we ever gotten a bunch of suggestions from our listeners of what we can do for our buys? I know, but do we have a portal for them to fill? A portal? Fill our portal?
What do you mean? Or some sort of a site they can put all these recommendations so we can stop listening to Sean's shitty buys. But also, it's not the shitty buys. No, it's not. It's the way he goes. It's the way he goes, blah, blah, blah, blah, and he goes, yeah, so also I was thinking that,
and you're like, fuck, dude. Here it comes. What are you doing? No, I was gonna say, what does Stye, what does Jason Stye rhyme with? No, that's no good. Will, you got one? I don't have one.
No, that's, I'm no, I'm glad that it's. You should be guest- Will, you got one? I don't have one. That's mine. No, that's... No, I'm glad that it's... You should be guest-related. You know, it should be tied into the guest somehow. Well, I mean... Skyfall, its original title was... Vy-e-fall! Hahaha! Sounds like you got yourselves in a little bind.
Ah! Robbie! SmartLess SmartLess SmartLess SmartLess SmartLess SmartLess SmartLess is 100% organic
and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armgerf. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.